playing a wonderful tournament indeed is
the french superstar maxine vashila grav
maximum this position i have on the
board right now uh pretty dead you came
in with a bit of a novel idea with b3
bishop a3 queen f3
did you feel like there was going to be
real action on the board with this idea
i was hoping so um i faced it
with black against david baravian in the
world cup in some rapid game
um and i don't know i felt like i have
lots of pressure but
um
wesley played some
good moves i thought
the way he played with g6 knight g7
it wouldn't never been time to play f6
but the problem is after qd6 i don't
have queen h6 because f6 knight h5 let's
get that because that's the board yeah
this is a critical moment so
um
yeah like g3 here
i'm not completely sure actually that
that was coarse maybe i should go queen
d2 but it also didn't felt like it's
enough
um
condition to go knight f4 of course
but yeah this shouldn't be much and the
thing is after conditions are intended
queen h6
f6 knight h5
but you just take on h5 you play rook e7
and
maybe i'm like
i have problems because
the wooken hr is not comfortable and i
don't have rocky
also that's important because you take
and after rook g3 of bishop g4 curving
so then i exchanged queens and well
given the tournament situation uh i was
not gonna take too
excited
explain that to us uh given the
tournament situation you say you're not
going to take too many risks
um well of course like it's a situation
that permitted me to to get more
initiative i would have played nobody
but i don't think it's wise to you know
in an equal position to force things
because i'm alpha point ahead
so no no reason to escape
are you still thinking grand chess tour
or a second place which looks like
you've wrapped up second place uh
no no no no
on the tour i'm
doesn't really matter honestly but uh
i'm more thinking about tournament
victory
you wanna you wanna win it all
i mean at this point i might as well try
uh if lanier wins today and there's a
tie for first
your efforts to go into tomorrow's game
knowing he's got he's got black against
wesley
um
you know
we'll take it step by step anyway i'm
playing uh shout with black tomorrow so
definitely it will be
that's
also why i was hoping to put in more
pressure today but um it wasn't the case
all right well thank you very much for
joining us and good luck tomorrow uh
maxine i have a quick question for you
because i just wanted to
ask you for your judgment
on the following variation you've just
played the move queen f3 in here
in studio alejandro and i were we're
looking at an exchange sacrifice we
wanted to ask your opinion of what you
thought about the move knight f5
bishop takes
f8 knight takes d4 well you might guess
that this isn't my nuts
you had prepared queen
takes
f6 well it is a move
okay
it is it is a movement it is
not revealing not spilling out those
variations very nice very nice we we got
it we enjoyed ourselves let's put it
that way uh thank you and good luck uh
tomorrow maxine thank you very much well
wonderful wonderful